um so we we're gonna have like a new
session today and you know to massage me
to share that station so we are very
happy of having your race mode that's
gonna present causal inference from
combined observational and
interventional data so your issue the
flaws is yours and anytime that we have
a question i will let you know me or
thomas and the person will ask the
question directly thank you very much
okay thanks
thanks a lot um
it's sad that i couldn't be there with
you
physically but at least i'm very happy
that i can participate virtually and i
would like to thank the organizers for
organizing a very interesting workshop
um the work i'm going to present is
joint work with maximilian ilse patrick
forrey
and max welling we're all from the
university of amsterdam um
before i continue let me check can you
hear me well enough
yes
yes okay thanks
um so the motivation behind this work
comes from questions like the following
for example how well does a booster
vaccination protect against covet
which i remember was a very relevant
question a few months ago perhaps now
it's a little less relevant but anyway
this is a simple question to post but
it's not so easy to answer
um of course we can make use of the gold
standards in principle using
interventional data so we could set up a
randomized controlled trial
um and use that to
to estimate the effects causal effect of
the booster vaccination
but there it could be unfeasible to set
up such a randomized controlled trial
because perhaps you want to immediately
decide who is going to get the booster
and not wait for some study that might
take a year
could also be unethical
so
the question is can we make use of
observational data instead perhaps
of course the well-known problem here is
that of confounding
for example there can be person
if many persons that
decides to get a booster vaccination
also take other measures so it's perhaps
the more
cautious persons that decide to get a
booster
then
we don't know whether the
difference in the probability to get
affected that we see is due to the
booster or due to other
things
so
the standard solution in a way is to try
to observe all potential confounders
for example h could be one of those
confounders and try to adjust for them
but of course
how do you know whether you have
observed all potential confounders and
in practice there will always be some
remaining unobserved confounding uh
what's what about it
so in this work we basically propose a
principled approach um we're not going
to solve this question above but we do
propose a principled approach
to obtaining a more accurate estimates
of causal effects by combining
observational and interventional data
and
the estimates we hope to
that they are more accurate than which
you would get if you would only make use
of the interventional data
even if there is unobserved
so
the main technical tool
here will be that of what we call a
causal reduction
so i will first explain
what we mean by that
the high level idea is the following
and take some causal model it could be
of
your favorite type
for example in this presentation i will
be making use of causal based nets
but you can use it to do it you can do
the same construction for other causal
models
and suppose it has an observed variable
x a treatment variable y an outcome
variable and suppose it has latent
confounders and it could be
an arbitrary number of them so k
unobserved common causes of x and y that
are explicitly
accounted for in the model
or alternatively you could start from a
joint distribution of potential outcomes
x y and
the potential outcomes
for y if we set x to a certain value
small x and that satisfy the consistency
assumption
then our goal would be to get the in a
way the most parsimonious
parameterization
for jointly modeling both the
observational distribution so the joint
distribution in the observational regime
of treatment and the outcome
and the interventional distributions
and that i will denote using the do
operator so as the distribution of y
if we do x
and this is just
the distribution of the potential
outcome y of x
so what we will do is define a causal
reduction that takes a causal model as
inputs
and it modifies this so it outputs
another causal model and that is
interventionally equivalent so it will
preserve the the observational
distribution and the interventional
distributions but often it has a smaller
latent variable space
how do we do this well as a
series of
four steps
in the first step suppose we have this
causal basic network that i
sketched here it could have a very
complicated latent structure but all
these z's are latent common causes of x
and y treatment are not and outcome
the first step is just to combine all
these latent confounders z1 to zk into
one
combined confounder z that has all these
as components
and that's a quite a boring step
um but at least it makes well it gives
you a cleaner picture
and on the right hand side
the second step is that we introduce a
latent copy w of x
so here we
add this w variable between z and x
we assume it to be latent
and
basically it must be must have the same
value as x so the
distribution of x given w
it's just a point
well a delta kernel
and so there's this deterministic
relationship
that i indicate in the graph by using
these double circles so x is a
because there's a double circle around x
it's a deterministic function of its
parents
now in the next step this is perhaps the
most exciting one we change the
directionality of the arrow between w
and
z um
and that is basically just a
refactorization
um first we had a joint distribution of
z and w
uh factorized in one way
as
and and but we can turn it around
as you see on the bottom of the slide
unfortunately i don't have a mouse
pointer to illustrate things but i hope
this is clear
um this um
well of course preserves the joint
distribution of w and z in our model
the last step is that we net can now
integrate over z
um
so we can marginalize z out
and that gives us the model on the
bottom
where we have this new kernel markov
kernel q of y
um and we have
this q of w which is actually the same
as the
observational distribution of x the
treatment
okay so a few simple steps
and
each step basically preserves the
observational distribution and the
interventional distributions
and we have ended up with a causal model
with a single confounder w
and whose
that takes values in the same space as
the treatment
and so this is where we may have
really reduced this the size of the
latent space observationally
in the observational regime x has the
same value as w
and our model parameters are now the
marginal distribution of the treatment
in the observational regime and this
mark of colonel q of y
if there are no questions about this
then i will
continue
otherwise perhaps i can clarify
something no then i will just continue
always there is a quick question there
is a question i think it's quick
um can you go back to the previous slide
yes so
why do you have an arrow from w
to y if w is equal to x and x already
goes to y
um
maybe this illustrates the fact that i
did not understand
um yeah okay i kind of understand your
question but um i need i need this
because um there can be a difference
i i mean if i intervene on x to set x to
a certain value small x
then um
things are different i haven't
illustrated this graphically i only gave
you the formula for p of y given dou x
but basically to be able to represent
both the observational distribution and
the interventional distributions at the
same time i need that
does it answer your question
he's okay with the answer i guess okay
okay
um
okay so we
sorry seriously there's more
i mean i understood the answer you gave
from a technical point of view
i'm just trying to understand it a bit
from a physical point of view so the
idea is that
if i don't intervene on x
for sure x will be
the same value as w
but i can intervene on x and set it to
some other value which won't change w
right
i mean then you'll get a different
interventional
marginals blah blah blah
but
can you give me an example of a
situation like that i mean i just can't
think of any plausible situation that
would have that structure that on the
one hand w completely determines x but
on the other hand i can intervene on x
and not affect w at all
um so
basically w just represents the value
that
x
would have had observationally you can
think about it like that
um
and to be able to represent the
confounding
um
that has to interact also with y
so y must depend on i mean there was
this latent confounder right that's gave
rise in our original model
we have actually all these latent
confounders that could give rise to
dependence between x and y even if
there's no
even if there would be no effects of x
on y so if the arrow from x to y
is not there
and and that is basically also why we
need
here the arrow from w to y and from w to
x to
to realize that dependency
even even if there would be no direct
effect from x2
does that help
okay
you could continue
um okay now
often we also have some observed
confounders
uh for example h in the booster
vaccination example might be available
as a measured
confounder
we can then do the
same basically the same derivation in
the presence of
is observed in founder c i won't go into
detail here but the four
[Music]
diagrams illustrate the same series of
steps as before but now we also have
this variable c
and this
basically
gives
a causal reduction
that preserves the conditional
distribution of treatment and outcome
given c and also the interventional
distribution of outcome given that we
intervene on treatment and conditional
on
c
um but it doesn't
perhaps you would you you might have
expected that it preserves all the
interventional distributions in the
model bus here i would like to point out
that it doesn't preserve all of them
but the two interesting ones are
preserved
okay um let's move on
to causal inference and let's start with
considering the discrete case
so
the reduced causal model
if all the variables are discrete um
these are the same formulas as before
but now with sums instead of intervals
um and if you look at the formulas uh
then um the interventional distribution
of y given to x
that's the sum over w
uh of a
product of two factors
and we can split it into
um
one term where w equals x
and the remaining w's that are unequal
to x and the the
the term where w equals x that is
actually the same one
that ends up in the observational
joint density of x and y
um
and now in this
remaining sum over the other values of w
unequal to x we can now simply bound the
vectors that are there because they have
to be between zero and one and then we
obtain with this bounds as written there
and
this is known as these are known as the
natural bounce by menski and meghan 1998
and so this is not new but
perhaps this is a nice derivation of
these
bounds and you also
can do a similar derivation in the
presence of observed confounders c
um
now how can we
estimate the causal effects from data
well we can
do maximum likelihood estimation in this
case also from combined data so let us
first choose parameterization
we can choose these parameters the phi
and the theta parameters for the
observational
they
encode the observational distribution
and the psi parameters for the
interventional distributions
and they're of course subject to
non-negativity and normalization
constraints but in addition they have to
satisfy this natural bond as we just saw
now suppose we have observational data
and interventional data then we can just
write down the total log likelihood
of the data
and it nicely splits into an
observational and interventional term
where the observational term only
depends on the observational data and
observational parameters
the interventional term only depends on
the interventional data dimensional
parameters but the parameters are
actually coupled through these natural
bonds
so there is some interaction between the
two terms going on
now i don't know of a closed form
solution for this problem but you can
[Music]
you can always optimize it numerically
um but we can gain some intuition of
what it's doing
by considering
the limits where the observational
sample size tends to infinity
but we keep the number of interventional
samples fixed
because there the observational term
will dominate the log likelihoods so we
will just end up with the standard
maximum likelihood estimators
for the phi and theta parameters
um that we would have got yeah that that
we get from only looking at the
observational data
um and then we can
make use of this natural bound
which is now has become a bound on the
side parameters
and if the standard maximum likelihood
estimator
for the interventional data
satisfies the bound then
that will be our estimator for the side
parameters but if it violates the bound
then basically the balance series has
kind of
it clips the value of this estimator and
in that way we can end up with a more
accurate estimate
so here's an example to get a feeling
for
how this can be exploited
so consider we consider an extreme value
for the probability of treatment in the
observational data
and this could correspond with for
example a treatment with a new vaccine
because then we may have lots of
observational data lying around
but in the observational regime
everyone would be untreated simply
because it's the new vaccine that hasn't
been used before so
from the observational data we can get
an accurate estimate of
for example the conditional probability
of
remaining healthy
[Music]
given that you're not treated
um on the other hand there might be a
small randomized controlled trial where
we have two groups treatment group and
the no treatment group consisting of 100
persons each
and from that we can estimate these
interventional quantities
but they will have large
confidence intervals
so the difference that we might see in
the randomized controlled trials
might not be significant
now
because in the observational setting
everyone was untreated the bound
actually becomes sharp
and this quantity in red the probability
of y given that we
set
that we
intervene to give no treatment
is actually equal to the marginal
probability in the observational regime
of the outcome
so we can also estimate that much more
accurately
um and then if you do that you find in
this case for these numbers that there
might be that there is a significant
effect
of the vaccine
uh on the outcome
and you also realize yes
just a quick question that when you're
saying that it's a randomized trial
there you mean right it's right it has
to be
has to be a random sample that is then
randomized
in reality you might worry the people
that are volunteering to be in the
randomized trial and not like the people
in the observational studies ah yeah so
it's very uh yeah the underlying
assumption here is that the two
populations in the observational study
and in the randomized control trial are
the same or well not the same but
are kind of
they have the same features
so so that is indeed an important
assumption here
um
but remember that we can also uh
in the presence of the covariates
we can also perhaps look at
subpopulations that are the same
when we do this
so under that assumption we can we can
get this improvement in the in the
estimator but you can also see that
[Music]
perhaps it would have made sense to set
up the randomized control trial
differently namely to assign everyone
just to the treatment group because then
you get also more accurate estimates for
p of y given do x equals one
and that gives you a more accurate
estimate of the average tree
um what can we do in the continuous case
so actually i don't know if
i don't know if the if this idea is
new or if anyone is actually already
doing this but um i thought it's a
nice way to exploit these these bounds
and it could be practically relevant
actually
but let's move on to the continuous case
now
how much more how much time do i have 15
more minutes
um
three
27 yes
so
in case treatment and outcome are
continuous for example if we are
estimating those response curves or even
quantile those response curves
then we can make use of this
reparameterization trick to parametrize
markov kernels by deterministic
functions
um so also this is a fairly standard
trick
graphically
it looks like this if you have this
markov kernel p of y given x
and then we can
represent it
as a
y being a deterministic function of x
and some independent noise variable u
and where we can
assume that u has a multivariate
gaussian distribution
uh in the same space as y
um
there is yes
you have 17 minutes sorry
17 okay thanks
so
we can
um
so on the top left you see basically our
reduced causal model and we can now
use this reparameterization trick first
on w
so we turn w into a deterministic
function of c and some
independent noise variable u
and then we can actually integrate out
or even substitute out the w from the
model
uh we end up with the third graph on top
and then finally we can apply the
re-parametrization trick to y
to write it as a function of
its parents c and x and a new
noise variable v
that is independent of u
and c
attacks
um
and then we end up with this structural
causal model parameterization
and that is written here
um
so i guess that is if you're familiar
with structure calls and models
because it should be clear
what's going on here now
um the next step if you want to do calls
inference uh
would be to to pick
the functions f and g
in a convenient function class
so basically we have kind of used the
freedom
in choosing the functions f and g to
already fix the distribution of the
noise variables u and v so we don't have
to infer the
distribution of u and v from the data we
just have to infer these functions f and
g
so we can pick them in some function
class
for example we can assume them to be
linear
and that that will be
[Music]
the next slide what the next slide is
about
or
we can
look at nonlinear functions here
and that will then
be the next step after looking at the
linear case
and we can then simply again optimize
the total log likelihood of these
functions
okay so let's first look at the linear
case
here we can actually uh
derive
also some constraints
so this would be kind of a linear
gaussian analog of the the natural
bounds
so suppose we have a linear gaussian
structure called causal model or
structural equation model
and it has these two variables x and y y
is not an ancestor of x
then we can model um
the observational and the interventional
distributions
kind of naively with using these
parameters where we
might think that they are independent
objects
but
by making use of the causal reduction
you can see
that the two constraints here at the
bottom actually must hold so there are
constraints between the parameters
these are now equality constraints
i also don't know really so to to the
best of my knowledge these are also new
constraints
and we haven't really pursued what one
can do with them because we wanted to
move on with
the more realistic
non-linear models
where we made use of normalizing flows
so perhaps going back to this
to these equations here
normalizing flows in case you haven't
heard of them they come from the deep
learning
neural network learning communities and
they are basically
[Music]
function classes
um
that have some nice properties
so here if you look at this equation x
is f of c comma u
then you can think about this as being
a change of variables from u to x that
also depends on c
to conditional on c we have a change of
variables from u to x
um
and if you then
calculate the density of x
conditional on c
you'll get
things like the jacobian of f and the
inverse perhaps
and so the nice properties of
normalizing flows are that
you can easily calculate their inverses
and the jacobian and their inverse
jacobian
so basically that allows you to
easily do maximum likelihoods
with these functions
and also well the neural network people
have tried to make these function
classes as flexible as possible
so that you uh
yeah try to
in a way be as uh yeah that you
basically can try
modeling anything
with it
so that's something we just
used
um
and here's what we what we got
um
so this takes a little
uh effort to explain what you see here
um on the top left you see
samples from um
the true model
and the true model was not picked to be
in the modeling class that we that we
use for
estimating it
and the blue
samples the blue data points the blue
dots here are from the observational
distribution and the yellow ones are
from the interventional distributions so
you can see that there is a difference
between the two so there's some
confounding in the observational regime
um now on the top right
you see what
we get if you use only 50 interventional
samples so the yellow dots we take 50 of
them randomly and we train the model
and then we sample from the model again
then we have reconstructed
the interventional density
interventional distributions
in the way that you see in the top right
scatter plot so this is not a perfect
reconstruction but it's
a reasonable one perhaps
but what happens now if you also make
use of the observational data so the
blue dots so if we also use 1 000
observational samples
and jointly train
from
these 1000 observational samples and the
15 dimensional samples then we end up
with the reconstruction that you see in
the bottom left
and if you look at the yellow
dots there
then this looks like a more a better
reconstruction
of what you see in the true model
than if we don't use the observational
data
so
well this is uh
one example so this is not yet a proof
that this always works
in the paper we give 10 of these
examples so that's still mother proof
we also try to some to quantify
um
how much one can gain here
so but what we did was we used the log
lot the interventional log likelihood as
a loss function
and
we found that basically
if you're allowed to make use of
additional observational samples during
training
then you can basically reduce the number
of interventional samples that you need
by a factor of two roughly
um without sacrificing the accuracy of
your reconstruction
so that is also i think quite promising
even though we don't really understand
what this method is doing so it's a bit
of a black box
but this also looks quite promising
so the contributions in this work is
that we propose this technique of causal
reduction
um
that may give you a more parsimonious
parameterization while preserving
observational and interventional
distributions
at least for this setting of the
treatment and one outcome variable
and we use this to derive constraints
between the parameters
in several cases and
to motivate certain causal effect
estimators from combined data
and well to conclude and perhaps some
food for discussion
i hope to have convinced you that causal
inference may actually benefit from the
presence of confounded observational
data
without making very strong assumptions
somehow it seems as if the causal
reduction is the opposite of the causal
inflation technique because here we try
to reduce the latent space whereas in
causal inflation you try to blow it up
i'm not sure if there's more to it than
this
this observation but
i found it interesting
um
now since this is also works about about
quantum
physics and
perhaps bell-type inequalities
i was wondering
in which way the observable constraints
that we find here due to latent
confounding are related to
say the
clouser horn shimoni holt inequalities
of course we are looking at a simpler
setting so we have only one treatment
and one outcome variable
whereas in the the bell type
inequalities you typically have two
treatments and two outcomes
but i'm not really an expert on on that
literature so perhaps
[Music]
there's a relationship that i i'm not
unaware of
um i was also wondering
in which way well whether quantum
mechanics allows for a violation of the
natural bounds perhaps and if there are
quantum natural bounds
so
perhaps if you have some ideas about
this and
be happy to
hear your thoughts on this
and well
anything i have
left out of the presentation you can
read that in our preprint so thanks a
lot for your attention
any questions
yes
comments yes
irs uh it's robin here um
talk um
so um presumably you could have done
that with a swig right you could have
had
you split the node x in a swig like way
and done everything you did
um i guess so
at some point i also realized that the
construction is very speed-like um
but i'm not sure in which way this
gains you anything this insight
um guess the other thing is i don't know
if you know but people in
um
like you know
who do randomized trials they actually
do use
um you know general populations as
control groups
in the in the way that i i presented
yeah here
okay so that's uh that's great and then
we have been reinventing the wheel
without knowing
it's good to know it
so do you have a pointer to uh
to a paper where this is
written down
not off the top of my head but i don't
suppose it would be hard to find
okay but if you know it's actually the
control group or something then you
probably would find it okay yeah thanks
so now if you take the bell scenario and
you do the same
um
i i guess that
you will have a which is a deterministic
function of
the you call it the treatment x right so
a is the outcome one of the two outcomes
it would be a deterministic function
function of the treatment
and the latin variable right
um if you use your technique in the bell
center so
oh in the bell scenario
um
so y will be a deterministic function
yeah of uh of x and uh this w indeed
so i okay for sure this in quantum
mechanics you you are not allowed to do
so
your technique is not i guess right it's
not valid for quantum mechanics and
you may find better inequalities like
this
so it's not valid in quantum mechanics
you're saying
so so in quadrant
what happens is really this output a is
non-deterministic and you cannot imagine
it as some
hidden determinicity somewhere right
it's really attached to what is quantum
mechanics this is fundamentally
random
right so you can't use the same
technique here but you can still wonder
whether you have some kind of bounce in
quantum mechanics
similar to
the natural bands or
are you claiming that
i i would not be surprised that uh you
are finding bell inequality in the bell
scenario with your technique because
okay you you really have a somehow if
you start to assume that it's
deterministic then it becomes classical
information but okay
it's not clear for me how to write it
down but uh i would not be surprised
that you exactly obtain uh chsh for
instance okay but
have people looked into kind of a chsh
inequality if you only have one
treatment and one outcome
so eli is saying that i'm
wrong so
maybe okay
this has to be worked out
okay
okay
maybe
but i think we can get chch
h s h equation inequality with a
treatment the binary treatment and the
binary outcome
you can you think okay
yeah i think this is definitely worth a
longer follow-up conversation
to my mind
although determinism was used in in this
particular proof
it wasn't the critical aspect right the
the factorization into kernels and the
joint distribution over the kernels as
robin was saying you could do this with
a swig and all that logic is quantum
valid the distribution's over the
kernels and so i think these natural
bounds in fact are exactly the same in
quantum theory um and it's only if we
sort of already use the
non-natural bounds the one that um
the balkan problems that we start to see
a difference
but this is a longer conversation
okay
thanks for sharing your thoughts on this
so just one follow-up question that i
missed that in the
first two settings you had you had this
um you had this restriction relating the
observational and interventional models
and then then you went when you were
which slides sorry which one
i mean in the beginning you had you had
these
uh constraints relating the
observational interventional
distributions
but then when you're optimizing the
normalized flows
are those just sort of automatically
built in or how is it it seemed like you
didn't
yeah so um
that's that's exactly a thing that
puzzles me um or perhaps i i got some
more insights very recently
um i believe that these natural bounds
like they're written here
they
they are informative
for the speed variables but if in the
continuous setting i think they become
completely non-informative the bounce
so
i'm not sure exactly what is going on
in that sense but i think
it has to do with with regular
regularization and with smoothness
assumptions
um
so perhaps that's an explanation why
we seem to get better estimates because
in our
normalizing flow parameterization
which is where is it here
we regularize the functions f and g
to have a certain
smoothness in the end and perhaps uh
that's what the observational data is
mainly used for to to uh sort of
get a good estimate of how smooth fmg
must be and then we can use the
interventional data exact uh
to to
to more completely estimate this
function g um but already starting with
a good smoothness um
so that that's
right now my conjecture of what's going
on here
um but in terms of bounce i haven't been
able to derive any boundary continuous
setting
it's interesting because you have you
could have the intuition i mean if you
could think about the use as
taking
using these taking continuous values but
it really only matters which side you
are at some threshold i mean maybe that
would violate your smoothness
assumptions going in there but anyway
yeah so far yeah i
i don't know exactly um it's bothering
me a bit that i can't
prove anything here well it seems to
work quite well
you know just to follow up on that in
the
you are thinking about the natural bond
and the continuity but i think
the the issue is the
is the discreteness of x
not necessarily y because even if y is
continuous you could construct the
natural bond in that
i think the the issue why you are you
are not able to construct the natural
bond is when x is continuous right yeah
that's true yeah and that's exactly the
case where it's uh
i think
there's no bound actually
if you don't assume any kind of
smoothness
yes yes so
there's an interesting paper in
biometrica from florian gonzalez that
tried to justify why you do not have uh
and this when x is continuous
okay yeah i think i even found a proof
today of this but uh
but perhaps it's already in that paper
then thanks for the pointer
so it wouldn't surprise me at all yeah
so it's it's interesting in the sense
that if you don't assume smoothness i
think that
um the observational and interventional
distribution in this continuous setting
are variationally independent
objects
[Music]
but still
completely
ignoring any kind of smoothness is also
perhaps rather drastic
online
i i can't hear what's going on in the
room but okay okay okay but you could
speak directly okay uh
i assume
i just had a quick comment about your
question concerning quantum analogs of
the natural bound it's
if you ask a kind of different question
which seems to be of the same flavor so
there's these
you know classical bounds like if you're
in the instrumental scenario you can
bound the average causal effect in terms
of observational data
and so you there has been a paper
written about if i replace the latent
classical variable in the instrumental
scenario with
a quantum source so it becomes the
quantum version of the instrumental
scenario do the bounds on the average
causal effect change and the answer in
that situation is yes they do
so it's it's just it's a similar flavor
of question to yours but in this okay
there has been some previous work that
kind of in that sense that sort of
relation between the
interventional and the observational can
be different in certain circumstances in
the quantum realm
okay
if if you could uh if you know which
paper it is
you have more questions
so maybe let's thank yours for the
very nice presentation
thank you very much
i think we have a break now it's gonna
be five minutes